[MUSIC PLAYING]
KERRY ANN KING: Hi, everybody.
Welcome.
If you don't know who I
am, I'm Kerry Ann King.
I do fitness stuff
here in the office.
And this is Will Dean.
He is the founder and
CEO of Tough Mudder.
I have to look at my notes here.
$100 million in annual revenue,
$13 million for charity,
Crain's 40 Under 40,
Fortune's 40 Under 40.
150,000 Twitter followers
for Tough Mudder.
2.5 million people have
signed up for these races.
I had 3,000 people with the
logo tattooed on their bodies,
but evidently it's a little
bit higher than that now.
That's an amazing
thing to have built--
WILL DEAN: Thank you.
KERRY ANN KING: --off of,
let's run around in the mud
and run over some obstacles.
Now it's international.
There's TV.
I loved reading this book.
The best way I can
describe it is it's
a moving business book,
or a motivational book
with incredible business advice.
That's the only way
I can describe it.
It was actually quite touching.
And one of the things that
amazed me about reading it
was how deep this
really goes for you.
This concept might have come
to you at some point later
in life, but it really
begins with the beginning
of your story, kind of growing
up in something that I got
to experience
firsthand, which is
a depressed post-industrial
town in northern England.
WILL DEAN: Yes.
That's where I'm from.
And writing a book, it is such
a fascinating journey to go on.
And you start with
these ideas as
to what you're going to write
and you reflect a bit on it.
And I think I always
knew that, for me,
Tough Mudder was, as much as
it's a business and, of course,
a money making entity,
it is this purpose-driven
organization.
You're all fortunate
you also all work
at a purpose-driven organization
with a very clear mission,
here at Google.
But I think, as I
started to reflect
on the mission of
the company-- and we
talk about building
a global tribe that
lives the values of teamwork,
camaraderie, courage,
personal
accomplishment, and fun.
And you start asking
yourself the question--
which at the back of your mind
you already know the answer
to, but you start trying
to put it down on paper--
why did you do this?
And one of the things
that I certainly
realized as I looked through
my entire life-- starting
as a child and my experiences
then through to undergraduate,
five years in counterterrorism,
then the MBA program--
was this sense of always
being somewhere I didn't quite
feel like I fitted in.
And what's been
very interesting,
the reaction to the book so
far is so many other people
have said that that
was something that
really resonated with them.
And perhaps not something
we're all conscious of.
We spend our lives
walking around feeling
like we don't quite
fit in places,
and most other people are
also feeling the same way.
And to try and
answer your question,
I grew up in a part of England
where you don't generally
meet that many people.
Certainly if you're in
New York, you generally
don't meet many people who
are from South Yorkshire.
And people say, oh,
where's it near?
And you say, um, Sheffield.
And they go, never
heard of that.
And they say, is it near London?
And you're sort of
like, well, no, it's
the other end of the country.
And it's funny because
when I'm in London,
Brits will say, oh, your
family are from there.
And they're surprised
to hear, here's
a guy with a company
who's got a Harvard MBA.
And they say, oh, does your
family have land up there?
Because in their mind, that's
the only kind of person
that would be a successful
person in London who
started there.
I was fortunate my parents
were professional people,
but they were--
my dad is the one lawyer
in this town, [INAUDIBLE],,
which is a former
pit mining town,
and which has since
been quite decimated
with the loss of the mine.
And so I think that was a
very personal part for me,
this idea of a very, very tight
community kind of ripped apart
and what it means to be part
of something, a community,
where people look
out for one another.
And what that means
when you lose that
was definitely something
that definitely
in the back of my mind--
my parents still live there--
was part of what drove me
to create an event that
is very much about
community and people
coming together and
doing something together.
KERRY ANN KING: Yeah.
I felt that very much
reading the book,
that this kind of search
for solidarity that you
saw in yourself, that you also
saw in the world and decided
to create your own
solution for it.
We'll go back a little bit
to the foreign service,
but I just wanted to--
the moment where you realized
that that solidarity was
really necessary.
I think you were in a
triathlon, and that was--
WILL DEAN: I was.
I was getting my MBA.
And so I was in this
business school,
hyper-competitive
environment to start with,
where everyone's on these
kind of forced curves
as to how you're all doing.
And most people there are these
very Type A personalities.
So you put all those
people together, it
creates a kind of crazy outcome.
And I remember doing a
triathlon whilst I was there,
with some HBS colleagues.
And this was an event of
which there was absolutely
no danger I was going to win,
absolutely none whatsoever.
And I finished the swim
section, about to start the bike
section.
And you're in the
transition zone.
And the zipper on my
wetsuit had jammed,
and I just couldn't
get it undone myself.
And I turned to the guy next to
me, as you are to me right now,
and I said, can you
just pull on this?
And transition times really
matter in triathlons.
And the guy said no.
I mean, I was probably
asking for three,
five seconds of his time.
And that happened to me twice
before somebody helped me.
And I just found that so weird.
Because I'm sure they
weren't bad people,
but there was something about
the environment in which they
found themselves that just
frankly didn't bring out
the best in humanity.
And I thought a bit about this.
And for any of
you that have done
a marathon or a half
marathon, I don't
know if anyone in the room
has done one of those.
Anyone done a-- OK, a couple.
So when you do a marathon--
I've done a marathon--
the first question you
get when you've
done the marathon
is, oh, what time
did you do it in?
First question.
And so you answer that
question, and you say
whatever time you did it in.
And in my case, I was
aiming for sub-four hours,
and I achieved that.
And so I was happy enough.
And inevitably, someone then
says, oh, my brother-in-law
did it quicker.
And you're like,
oh, that's good.
And you feel like saying,
yeah, I know I didn't win.
I know those Kenyans were
a long way ahead of me.
And that got me thinking.
For most people, a
race isn't really
a race in the classic
sense of the word.
It's not about where
do you place overall.
It's much more about
personal achievement
and you have a goal in
mind, but it's not really
about other people.
And I thought, is it possible
to create an event that you
yourself still
achieve something,
but you're part of something
bigger than yourself,
and you can have fun and you
can do it as part of a team,
and you can also not take
yourself too seriously.
And it seemed, certainly
in the triathlon,
people were taking
themselves far too seriously
in what was an amateur event
of where the people next to me
were, by definition, also
midway down the field, as well.
And so that was certainly
the inspiration behind it.
KERRY ANN KING: Yeah.
And I feel like that sounds
to me very much in line
with how you approach all of the
problems that you're solving.
How do we use this tension
between personal achievement
and group achievement to
create the best outcome?
Rather than just, I got
to the top of the pile.
I hope you guys had fun, too.
WILL DEAN: No, and look, it's
something I really believe in.
I think a lot of our early
lives' education systems
tend to put very high emphasis
on individual achievement,
very high.
What mark did I get?
How did I do?
Are you smart, yes or no?
And the truth is,
in life, very few
of us can go and
be successful based
upon our individual
achievements.
Maybe writing, it's actually
one of the few examples
where it is kind of
about one person.
But even then, it's
not really just you.
You still have a
team around you--
editors, publishers,
book agents, et cetera.
But in a business environment,
it's very different.
I can say I founded
Tough Mudder,
but at best I'm 5%
of the equation--
at best, frankly far less.
It's about all the other
people in the company.
But far more than that,
it's about the community
and the tribe that's
kind of built up
around that, of
which now I'm frankly
a very small cog in
that bigger system.
And I think far too many people
talk about their achievement--
or think that achievements
are about things
you do on your own.
And some things in
life, that's true.
But the vast majority of things,
including the vast majority
of obstacles at Tough
Mudder to kind of bring it
back to the event,
they do require
you to work with other
people to get through.
And you can be proud of yourself
at the end of the course
that you did it, and you
got yourself through.
No one else carried you.
Or in most cases, no
one else carried you.
But they probably helped
you up Everest and some
of the other obstacles.
And I think there's something
in there about life,
a lesson in life, and
being willing to ask
for help, which I think a
lot of people struggle with.
KERRY ANN KING: So speaking of
being willing to ask for help,
I'd love to talk about those
early days of Tough Mudder.
It's this big international
organization now.
But as you can imagine,
it did not start that way.
Tell us about that first event.
WILL DEAN: Yes.
It was an amazing experience.
My co-founder and I,
we both had $10,000.
The total start-up
budget, $20,000.
We spent about $10,000
driving around fields
outside of New York trying to
figure out what the hell we
were looking for in
terms of a venue,
mostly getting
laughed out of town.
We eventually found a
ski hill just outside
of Allentown, Pennsylvania.
And having not grown
up in this country,
I genuinely thought Allentown
was a fictitious place only
in a Billy Joel song.
And so we found this ski hill.
We gave him a $1,000 deposit.
I honestly think they thought
they'd never see us again.
And we built this
very simple website,
really just a landing page
linked to a registration
platform on the back end.
And we were-- I don't know if
I'm allowed to use this word
whilst I'm over at Google--
but we were one of the first
advertisers on Facebook
back in 2010.
And I remember two weeks in,
we hadn't sold any tickets,
not one.
I think my sister had
bought one to test
the website was working for us.
And we had a price rise.
The first event, tickets
went from $50 to $60.
And at about 8:00 that
evening-- the price rise
was at midnight-- things
seemed to be slowing down.
And we'd sold 200 tickets.
And we were hoping to sell
500 for the first event.
And Guy, my co-founder,
and I, for the first time
in about three months, we went
for a beer on a Sunday evening.
We were exhausted.
We were working very hard.
We were subletting two desks in
this really warehouse building,
whilst [INAUDIBLE]
was still kind
of a warehouse
area before Equinox
and all the condos arrived.
And back then, I had
a BlackBerry Pearl.
Do you remember those phones?
People remember that?
It wasn't that long ago.
And I used to get an email every
single time we sold a ticket.
And I remember getting up-- we'd
only been in this bar for about
an hour or so--
and going to the restroom.
And I had over 1,000 emails.
And I was looking at this.
And every couple of
seconds, it was refreshing.
And I was like, wow, another
20 people bought tickets.
Wow, another 20
people bought tickets.
And we got to midnight, and
we'd sold 2,000 tickets.
And I remember my
heart was beating.
Sorry, I'm going to
knock the microphone off.
But my heart, it was so hard.
And I was excited.
At the time, I had
Citigroup badgering me
about paying back
my student loans
and getting quite
aggressive about that.
And then I remember Guy and I
looking at each other saying,
wow, we now actually have to put
on an event for 5,000 people.
And I always tell people
the first event was
an A-plus in terms
of ticket sales
and kind of proving the concept
in terms of market demand.
And Steph, who's
here-- was that?
You were both at
the first event.
I think I would say it was a
D-minus in terms of logistics.
AUDIENCE: That
sounds about right.
WILL DEAN: Yeah.
All right.
There we are.
AUDIENCE: Well, compared to now.
WILL DEAN: Yeah, no.
No, I understand.
I understand.
No, it was objectively
a D-minus by any stretch
of the imagination.
But we just about
got through it.
But it was-- I mean it
was-- everything that could
have gone wrong went wrong.
We totally failed to plan
the car parking correctly.
The road got backed up.
We ran out of water at the
water station within 20 minutes.
Most of the obstacles were
closed within the first hour.
The course which we thought
was seven miles long
turned out to only be four
and a half miles long.
And I remember this
thing started and then
coming back down into the
base area of the event.
And 35 minutes later, the first
person crossed the finish line.
And I thought, oh, God we've
made a horrible mistake here.
So we just about survived
that first event.
But it was very, very stressful
and we had really no idea
what we were getting in for.
And certainly now when I look
at the events and this kind
of army of trucks and warehouses
and event professionals
that kind of seamlessly
move around the world.
Last weekend, we
had four events on.
So a start wave was going
off with various time
zones across Europe and Asia
every 15 minutes for 48 hours.
And yeah, quite a far
cry from Allentown,
Pennsylvania only
seven years ago.
KERRY ANN KING: Which
brings up the question,
given that it was a D-minus,
what made you say, OK,
let's do that again.
That seems like a good--
aside from all the
ticket sales, because it
had to be more than that,
based on what I read.
WILL DEAN: I think
one of the things
to be successful-- certainly
in entrepreneurship,
but I suspect in
anything you do--
is to have this kind
of balanced optimism.
And I think sometimes
entrepreneurs have
this kind of wild optimism.
And then they inevitably
become a bit disappointed
when things don't all go
exactly as they planned
and become quite despondent.
But I think you
have to have this,
for want of a better term,
kind of balanced or cautious
optimism.
That yes, things won't
always go perfectly.
And yes, there'll be problems.
And you have to accept that many
of those, you can't anticipate.
But yet still have this kind of
belief that in the long term,
it will all work out.
And I think I do have that,
for better or for worse.
And I think for me that
came from believing-- well,
I had this data point that
showed there was market demand.
But over and above that,
that this was something,
I had this kind of gut
feeling, a hypothesis,
that this is something I
would do, my friends would do,
and there are other people out
there that felt the same way.
And none of the barriers
that I was coming to,
although some of them
were scary, none of them
felt insurmountable.
And I'm not going to tie
every single point back
to the obstacle
course, but I knew
there were obstacles out there.
I didn't quite know what
they were going to be.
And yes, they scared me,
but they didn't petrify me.
And I think that kind
of cautious optimism
is probably quite a key trait
when you're starting a company.
KERRY ANN KING: Yeah.
One of the other
things that struck me
about those early
days, reading the book,
is a sense of hunger,
sometimes literal,
certainly a hunger
for achievement
as part of the driving force.
WILL DEAN: I mean that
was certainly there.
My career-- I had spent five
years in counterterrorism,
which was really an
amazing five years.
I had started that after
9/11 and had this amazing set
of experiences when,
certainly in the UK,
the infrastructure in
place to at least deal
with Islamic terrorism
was very, very
limited back in 2001, 2002.
And so it was a very
entrepreneurial environment.
Funny thing to
say, but it really
was an entrepreneurial
environment.
You had lots of new problems.
You had all these people that
had spent their entire careers
thinking about the
Cold War and how
to deal with the Soviet threat.
And all of a sudden, a
completely new set of problems.
Old ways of working don't work.
And so you had all these
kind of bright young things
coming in, challenging
conventional wisdom,
getting to do new things.
And I remember going
to Gordon Brown when
he was the chancellor, our
finance minister, before he
became prime minister.
And we were asking
for 10 million pounds
to go and do this
thing in Pakistan.
And I remember him
saying, here's 12.
I mean, that was the environment
which we were in at the time.
Nowadays very, very different
in terms of budgets.
But it was an
amazing experience.
But I'd done that.
I had a great time.
I think concluded in the
long term it wasn't for me.
Tough place to work
on a sustained basis.
Also, as it was becoming
larger, becoming
a bit more bureaucratic.
And I got it into my
head I'd go to Harvard.
I'd go and get an MBA.
I'd learn about "business,"
whatever I thought that meant.
Not quite sure if I could
have really defined it then.
I certainly can't now.
And I had this sort
of two years that--
Harvard's not a bad
place, but it just
wasn't the right place--
at least Harvard Business
School is not a bad place.
It just really wasn't
the right place for me.
And so I'd left this career.
I've gone to this prestigious
university, which I kind of got
inside and didn't find quite
as prestigious or as impressive
as I thought I was going to.
And then I kind of came
out the other end of that,
and there's this kind
of, ugh, what now?
And I had this very clear
desire to build something
that, in my own small
way, I thought would
make a difference in the world.
And we don't pretend
at Tough Mudder
that we're curing
cancer or bringing peace
to the Middle East.
But we are getting
people to spend
time with their
friends-- at least
spend a few hours not
connected to their iPhones
or other smartphone devices that
run on other operating systems.
But I'm proud of that.
And I think--
I was only aged-- what was I
when I started the company?
28.
Yes, 28.
There was a desire
to prove myself.
I think there was a
kind of necessity.
In the early days,
it's quite binary.
It either fails, or it succeeds,
at least that's how it feels.
And you run very hard and you
make quite a lot of sacrifices
to do that.
KERRY ANN KING: But this is--
I have to bring this
up because this was not
Will's first venture.
WILL DEAN: No.
KERRY ANN KING: I know that
you had something in university
with T-shirts.
WILL DEAN: Yes.
A few things, yes.
KERRY ANN KING: And then you
sold bags for your school
in high school?
WILL DEAN: That's what I
did for my high school, yes.
KERRY ANN KING: Isn't there
even something in junior high
where you actually had an
entrepreneurial project going
on?
WILL DEAN: I did.
Amazingly in England,
it's getting better,
but it is not always the most
entrepreneurial of places.
And my mother recently asked
me if I sold Tough Mudder,
did I think I could get myself
a job in management consulting
still?
I suspect so.
But it isn't always that.
And I think people
probably think of it
differently about
risk and achievement
and those sort of things.
But one of the amazing
things in the UK
is if you're doing reasonably
well at school, age
16 you get to drop a subject.
And the British government
creates a limited liability
company for you and
they give you a mentor.
And there's about
six of you, and it's
called Young Enterprise.
And you're allowed to go and
trade as a limited liability
company, even though you're
a bunch of high school
kids, which was great.
And in the mid-1990s,
we had a static website.
And we kind of had
all these crazy ideas
of things we were going to do.
I mean we were like
16-, 17-year-old kids.
And I managed to convince a
company out of Minnesota that
made color changing
products--you remember
the Global Hypercolor T-shirts?
Some of you are old enough
to remember the early 1990s.
Anyway, so one of
the products they had
was color changing
nail polish or nail--
what do you call it here?
Varnish?
Nail polish?
KERRY ANN KING: Nail polish.
WILL DEAN: Nail polish.
I spend so much time between
Britain and the States,
I forget which words we use.
Nail polish in the States.
And obviously, I don't
use either nail polish
or nail vanish, but
you get my point.
And they were dealing with
these literally schoolboys.
And we had this static website
and we were calling them
from a payphone.
And they gave us the
distribution rights
to this color
changing nail polish.
And it was really
quite successful.
And we sold it through
all these trade fairs.
And I really think that's
probably where I got the bug.
And then I did other
things in that kind of vein
through high school
and then undergraduate.
So I really enjoyed that stuff.
And I thought I might,
when I finished undergrad,
go and start my own business.
But then I took the other
path that entrepreneurs
take and became a
counterterrorism officer,
as you do.
KERRY ANN KING: So
one of the things
that strikes me about
all of these endeavors,
maybe except for
the nail polish--
but all of the other
endeavors really
ended up being about
a sense of community.
Even the bags for
your high school,
they were kids
getting a bag that
said where they went to school.
It was really
interesting to me to see
that that was a running--
the desire to build a
business is a running theme,
but so is the desire
to create a tribe.
And that's how you talk
about Tough Mudders.
We have about-- how many
members of the tribe
are in the room today?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WILL DEAN: It counts.
It counts.
KERRY ANN KING: So yeah,
Google is certainly
a tribe of a
certain type, but we
have a sub-tribe of Google
Tough Mudders, as well.
But I think that's
such a key piece
of what a Tough Mudder means.
WILL DEAN: Well, I think it--
sometimes when I
say this, I worry
that people think
it sounds cynical,
because certainly I don't
think the company is this way.
But I think there is an unmet
human need for belonging.
And I think Tough Mudder allows
people to feel several things.
They feel part of something
bigger than themselves.
It doesn't take
itself too seriously.
There is an achievement
at the end of it
that you can tell all of your
friends on a Monday morning
that you did, post about it
on social media, et cetera.
And I think when I was
at business school--
and I'm not by any stretch
of the imagination--
and I'm not just saying this
because I'm at Google today--
anti-people that are going
to start tech businesses.
But I think when I was
at business school,
it was kind of taught
that the only kind of way
you could start a company was
to find the angel investor.
Well, it was-- if
you were at Harvard,
find three geeks from MIT, pair
them up with an angel investor,
then there's kind of five
steps of VC, and then your IPO.
And there's just a
playbook, and that's
what a "Harvard
entrepreneur" does.
And I'm not anti- that.
I'm not saying that's wrong.
But I reject the
notion that that's
the only way of doing it.
And I think when I look at-- and
part of why I wrote the book--
and certainly when I
look at Tough Mudder,
we didn't take outside capital.
And we're not a
tech-enabled business.
OK, we have a website.
But my father was a provincial
lawyer, and he has a website.
I'm not sure that makes
me a tech business.
And I think this idea
of creating something--
and I think a lot
of smart marketers,
product designers are good at
understanding the underlying
psychology of what people
want and they don't just
think about what are the
attributes of the product.
I mean, maybe if you're selling
soap powder that you only
care about whether it
gets your shirt clean.
But for Tough Mudder,
it's an experience.
And so it's much more than
just a rational purchase.
It taps into something
quite emotional.
And I've always, I
think, to some extent
had an intuitive
understanding of that.
But I've always found it
more interesting to operate
in that space, as well.
KERRY ANN KING: And do you feel
like the physical aspect of it
is part of--
could you create
community in that way
if it were a video game, a
concept that you actually
rejected at some point?
WILL DEAN: Yeah.
So I think the underlying value,
the mindset of Tough Mudder
is around this idea that we
should all try and do things
that challenge ourselves.
And those of you that have
come to a Tough Mudder, 15%,
20% of people are in
very, very good shape.
60% of people look
like most of the people
that you see walking around,
that you see in the gym
or walking around the streets
in a place like New York.
And then 15% or 20% of
people, candidly, I'm
kind of surprised they signed
up for a 12-mile event.
But good for them that they did.
And we've always
tried to be anything
but elitist in our
approach to what
it means to challenge yourself.
We don't have rules if you don't
complete one of the obstacles.
And that was something that
we decided very early on.
Because we were having people
with disabilities write to us
and say, I want to
do a Tough Mudder,
but I can't do this obstacle.
And I thought, if
life isn't hard enough
for you to start with, the fact
that you have to write to me
and ask for dispensation to
go around an obstacle, that's
just wrong.
That isn't how it should be.
Or the idea that you might be
punished or penalized for that
just seemed very wrong to me.
And so I think
yes, the community
is born out of the
fact that everybody
has been through this
experience together.
If you see another
Tough Mudder running
in the park in a
Tough Mudder shirt,
probably you will
high-five them.
Certainly, if you see someone
in the World's Toughest Mudder
gear--
this guy has done, if
you hadn't noticed,
he's done a World's
Toughest, which
is the 24-hour
nonstop Tough Mudder.
And that event literally
does go on for 24 hours.
People do as many loops
of the course as they can.
And that is definitely
a community.
I think you'd agree, right?
And that exists way beyond
the event weekend itself.
And people get together.
They make friends through it.
And I do think it's
born out of the fact
that people have been through
something that challenged
them physically, some
more than others,
but also scared them
a little in places.
Some of the obstacles
are a bit intimidating,
like Electroshock Therapy,
the wires you run through,
or Arctic Enema, which is
the dumpster full of ice.
And I think yes, that
kind of underpins it.
But one of the things--
I know I'm giving you
quite a long answer here,
but it's a really
important part of the book
and important part
of the company--
one of the things
I'm most proud of
is I remember being on the start
line of the first ever event
in the UK back in 2012.
And for better or
for worse in England,
you can tell very, very
quickly where someone's from,
both geographically, and
we have our class system.
I'm not defending it.
It just is what it is.
You can tell where someone's
from geographically.
You can tell very quickly
how much education they have.
You can probably
infer quite a lot
about their socioeconomic
background, et cetera, really
within two or three seconds.
And I remember being
on the start line
and just hearing all these very
different accents and thinking,
wow, I would have
never have guessed
that you would have such
a diverse group of people
who, when they all get in the
mud, are all just one group.
And whether they arrived in
a 15-year-old beat-up truck
or a brand-new 7 Series
BMW is irrelevant.
You're just all people helping
each other out in the mud.
And I think there's something
about it, it's a leveler.
It's about something
that frankly strips away
some of the bullshit that we as
adults all surround ourselves
with.
And I think it's a
lot of what explains
why we've been successful.
KERRY ANN KING: And I
feel like you really
tried to instantiate
a very similar ethos
inside the company, as well,
so that this is not something
that lives out
there for the users,
but not inside the company.
WILL DEAN: Completely.
I think the best companies--
I think successful brands
have to ultimately practice
what they preach.
And they have to believe in
their values and their mission.
And sometimes
internally-- I'll say
that's true even at Philip
Morris, which is probably
an organization that many of us
don't have very much time for.
They have a value
of adult choice.
That is something
they believe in.
And you don't go and
work at Philip Morris
unless you believe that--
that or you have to have
some views of the world which
I perhaps wouldn't agree with.
But I think most people
there do give that reason.
In that way, and maybe
in that way alone,
Tough Mudder is similar
to Philip Morris,
that people come
to Tough Mudder--
because they could get a better
paycheck somewhere else in New
York City, for sure--
because they believe
in what we're doing.
They believe in the mission.
And we try to create a culture
that's consistent with that.
And one of the things I always
say about company culture
is it has nothing to do with
cold beer in the fridge,
or foosball tables, or any of
that stuff, which sometimes I
think gets written
about when we're
talking about
entrepreneurial environments.
It's very, very simple.
Culture is about
how do people behave
when their boss isn't looking.
It's behavioral norms.
That's all it is.
So what do people do when
their boss isn't looking?
When I walk by, people
quickly shut down Facebook.
And I'm like, do
you really think
I don't believe
you check Facebook?
Why are you hiding it from me?
It's just silly.
And mostly, most of the
people at Tough Mudder
aren't like that.
And if they are, they
probably don't stay with us
all that long.
And here's the really
important point.
You have to--
I get some flak from
the media from this.
I say people who work at Tough
Mudder should do the events.
And I don't mean
every single weekend.
But they should do one probably
at least once a season,
so they can see the
people out there.
They can interact
with the community.
They can understand
what it's all about.
And some people say, well,
isn't that very elitist?
And I say, I'm not saying
they have to win an event.
I'm just saying they
should take part in it.
And I really believe that stuff.
And I do believe the
great companies have
internal culture that are
consistent with their brand
values.
KERRY ANN KING: And
that's something
that I feel like you did
struggle a little bit
with, in terms of scaling and
keeping that culture solid
and what you wanted it to be.
WILL DEAN: Definitely.
Yeah.
We have something called
the Legionnaire program,
which is the program
for the repeat Mudders.
And I wanted to call that
the Repeat Offenders.
And we just hired somebody from
a very large, very, very large,
publicly traded company.
She was very senior
in marketing there,
and she'd come in to be our CMO.
And she really grandstanded
me on this point.
She said, Will, people are
going to hear repeat offenders,
they're going to think
violent offenders.
People are going to go
to domestic violence,
and you're going to be
saying that Tough Mudders are
all these things.
And I said, but I
just don't think
the vast majority of
people will go there.
I just don't.
She said, well, they could.
I said, well, look, I
mean almost anything
is theoretically possible.
But that can't be the standard
that we hold ourselves to.
And she said, well,
someone might be offended.
I mean look-- the name of
the company is Tough Mudder.
We're clearly-- the whole
name is a play on words.
And I remember this
being a situation where
I had lots of people kind of
trying to save me from myself,
this kind of conventional wisdom
getting the better of things.
And that's not to say
that I'm always right.
In fact, often I'm
wrong on things.
But we weren't having a
sensible, logical discussion.
There was disagreement,
but people
weren't being
disagreeable in the way
they were approaching it.
And yeah, that's a challenge.
And I think maintaining
culture-- you don't build
a culture, and then it's done.
It's not like a warehouse.
You're like, OK, boom,
finished, that works.
It's something that you have
to stay hyper vigilant of.
And I also get flak
because I, as people here
who are from Tough
Mudder will know,
I get very, very
fussy about people
doing things like washing
up dishes or turning lights
off in meeting rooms.
Because it's those
small things that
are indicative of an
environment where everyone's
pulling together as a team.
And if the event
is all about people
pulling together as a team
and you're not doing that
internally, it doesn't matter.
Clearly, dishes are
not a strategic matter
into themselves, but
I do think they're
indicative of something.
KERRY ANN KING: Yeah.
And that was one
of the things that
was so interesting to read about
how your faith in your vision
allowed you to correct course
and really lead to an even
greater expansion of the brand.
How do you keep the brand
authentic when it's on TV,
and on five continents,
and gyms and shoes and--
WILL DEAN: And it's
funny, because I
mean, this is, I'm sure, an
environment where people talk
about the importance of
failure and making mistakes
and learning from mistakes.
And it can all be a bit
cliche if you're not careful.
But lots of people have
come into Tough Mudder today
and they've been
very successful.
They worked hard at high school.
They got into a good university.
They then worked hard
through that college program.
They got into a great place.
And they've really
only ever experienced
modicums of success.
They haven't really ever dealt
with spectacular failure.
And you can tell this
because they give you
interview answers of when their
boss didn't like a presentation
they gave or something.
These are not the kind of
things that change someone's
worldview.
These are kind of minor slaps on
the wrist are the worst of it.
And I think it is hard to keep
pushing people to do new things
and taking risks.
And I think one of the
values of Tough Mudder
is also being
somewhat irreverent,
and challenging conventional
wisdom, and asking why.
It's very central to the idea.
Even the obstacle names, the
name of the company, I think
speak to that.
And it's hard.
And my role in the innovation
process I don't think
is to be the kind of
creative force, per se.
Whether I'm creative or
not is just irrelevant.
It's about creating
an environment where
it's permissive to
go and do things
that, in other environments,
people might not go and do
that.
So Electroshock Therapy
is a great example.
And I'll say, just go and do it.
They're like, well,
well, well, well.
Who else do you
want to check with?
I'm not saying this to brag,
but I control the Tough Mudder
board.
So I'll say, the
CEO has approved it.
The board's approved it.
Who else do you want to
approve this-- the pope?
I mean just please go and make
Electroshock Therapy work.
And I think trying to
empower people to do that.
They'll be like, well, what if?
What if it fails?
Well then, we won't do it again.
That's what will happen.
And things often don't work out.
And I think trying to
get people to reflect
on failure in a way
that doesn't become
this kind of painful
exercise can be quite hard.
And I think it's something you
either get or you don't get.
We use the 5 Whys tool a lot.
It's probably
something you use here
a lot to try and
understand what went wrong.
You really kind of dig
into the root causes.
Some people just hate that.
They just turn
themselves in knots
to try and avoid doing it.
And that person
probably isn't going
to enjoy Tough Mudder
in the long term.
And I try and be very
honest with people.
This is the Tough Mudder
employment satisfaction survey
results.
Nine out of 10 people
are really happy.
One in 10 people
are really unhappy.
I'm not going to try and
fix those one in 10 people
because they're not in the
six to seven out of 10 range.
They're probably not going
to be back at eight or nine
very soon.
In fact, they clearly
don't like it.
We're not the right
place for them.
Most people are
in New York City,
and they have other,
alternative career
options that they can go after.
Let them go do that,
because we are not
all things to all people.
And being very
comfortable with that,
and being very
comfortable with that
both in terms of a
hiring perspective,
but also as a brand perspective.
Some people say, ugh,
I hate Tough Mudder.
It's all about teamwork
and camaraderie.
Sometimes people even tell
me, it's not competitive,
it's un-American.
Well, it's true.
I'm not American.
That's very astute.
But it's funny.
Some people really kind of
have this visceral dislike
of an event that isn't
about competition.
There's something
wrong with it, that I'm
part of this movement of people
that gives all the kids medals
at high school, and I'm what's
wrong with American society.
Some people say that.
I'm like, OK, fine, don't
come and do my event.
That's OK.
KERRY ANN KING: Yeah.
Not that you need me to
jump to your defense,
but what's very clear
to me, as someone
who's never run a Tough Mudder,
is that this actually isn't
about not being competitive.
There is something keenly
competitive about it.
But it strikes a
beautiful balance
between competitive
and cooperative
that would be great if we could
strike it more in more places.
WILL DEAN: I mean I
think that's right.
And one of the
things I really do
miss from my time
in counterterrorism
was there was a very
deep sense of camaraderie
and never letting
other people fail.
But it was also an environment
that had quite a lot of Type A
people in it.
It absolutely did.
And I think there was this sense
about who's doing the best.
But there was this
sense as well,
of you don't let
people fall behind
because it really matters.
If things go horribly
wrong there, people die.
And so there's this
kind of unwritten rule
that you helped each other out.
And I miss that.
Because my experience,
not to bash Harvard,
was there was none of
that at business school.
And in fact, you were
very happy if someone
was bottom of the pile because
they were kind of propping up
that false curve.
Very, very different
from what I was used to.
KERRY ANN KING: So I want
to leave time for questions.
But I have to ask
you one last one.
Because reading the book,
one of the questions
that I had about you was,
OK, this is who this guy is.
This thing is so
deeply ingrained.
If this hadn't worked, what do
you think you would have done?
Because it just seems like
such a perfect project.
WILL DEAN: Well, look,
counterfactuals and hindsight
are wonderful things.
When I was starting
Tough Mudder,
I had no idea whether it
would be successful or not.
And I'm not sure that
ever completely goes away.
Even when you kind of get to
a certain level of success,
there's still this
question of, oh, well,
will people still be doing
it in five or 10 years' time?
I don't know if that
ever quite leaves you.
But when I started--
and I will answer
your question--
but the realization I came to
suddenly at age 28 was, look,
I'm not married, I
don't have a mortgage,
I don't have any dependents.
If I give this a year
or two of my life
and it doesn't work out, it's
unlikely when I'm 40 years old,
I'm not going to have
the things that matter.
And I think there's
something quite wrong in some
of what increasingly you do
see in elements of the culture
in Silicon Valley,
which is starting
to look in some ways quite
a lot like Wall Street.
It's all about who's
raised the most money.
It attracts a lot of
very Type A people.
Some of the people, they
may talk a good game
about building the future.
But I still have
people say to me, oh,
how much money has
Tough Mudder raised?
And I say, oh, we
haven't taken any money.
And people still say to
me, it's going to be OK.
And I'm like, yeah, I think
it will be, thank you.
But it still happens.
I promise you I am going
to answer the question.
KERRY ANN KING: No, it's OK.
WILL DEAN: But I
think it starts from--
for me, it really started
from saying, look, it's
going to be OK financially,
the things I need in life
to be happy.
I'm fortunate.
Not everyone does in life.
But I'm fortunate.
I'm reasonably well-educated.
I'm not unintelligent.
I'm reasonably hard working.
I'm going to check those
boxes one way or another.
So what would I have done?
I think one of
the obvious things
to go and do when you've got an
MBA is to go and do something
kind of consultancy related.
It pays the bills.
I spent my summer at Bain.
And I was always shocked by
how many people there said, I
really thought I was coming
to Bain for two years
and then I was going
to start my own thing.
And I've been here
seven years now.
I'm not quite sure
what happened there.
So I suspect I'd
have kind of bounced
into some kind of relatively
well-paid, comfortable,
slightly dull job.
And then within a year or
two, I'd have got bored
and started something
else, which probably
would have been about community
and doing things together,
because those are the
things I find interesting.
KERRY ANN KING: Yeah.
Having read the book,
I think that's what
you would have done.
And you actually got to one
of the key points for me
in the book, which is
the risk is worth taking.
And maybe even when
you're not 28 and don't
have a mortgage,
maybe even when you
have a mortgage and a family,
that if the energy is there--
WILL DEAN: If you believe in
what you're doing, for sure.
I think starting new
companies, your own company,
is one of the most
rewarding things you can do.
And it isn't always fun
and frankly, at times, it's
very lonely.
And I try and touch
on that in the book.
It's not for everyone.
I sometimes see these books
that are called things
like "Anyone Can Do It."
Well, that's a bit like saying
anyone can have a six-pack.
I mean it's technically
true, but most of us
don't really want to go
through the pain to achieve it.
And I think I'm very proud
of what we've achieved.
I'm very pleased I did it.
It certainly wasn't
easy at times.
But I'm not one of these people
that tells everyone, oh, you
should all go and start
your own companies, too.
I think it's a very
personal choice.
And I think you have to be
very clear why you're doing it
and what you hope to achieve.
And you have to own your
own definition of success.
The second you allow anybody
else to try and impose that
upon you, you're going
to have real problems.
And I think that's
very important
when you're starting your own--
whatever the organization
does, but certainly
if you're starting a company.
KERRY ANN KING: So I would
love to open the floor up
for questions.
And we have a microphone.
Allen's there with the mic.
Does anybody--
AUDIENCE: Hi, Will.
Kerry may have told
you, but every year we
organize a little race
on the Hudson River.
It's a little 5K.
And there's something
that keeps me up all night
that I wonder how you deal with.
Because we don't have
obstacles, but you can get
run over by a police tow truck.
How do you deal with
that fear of someone
might get hurt at my event?
WILL DEAN: Yeah.
So let me give you the
kind of stock answer
I give generally when I'm
asked this, which is true.
The most dangerous part
of doing a Tough Mudder
is the drive to a Tough Mudder.
You are far more likely
to injure yourself
getting yourself
to the start line
than what happens on course.
I am proud of the safety
systems we have in place.
All of the obstacles do have
medics and divers in place.
But when I started the
business, I thought,
if we're moderately successful,
we will have injuries or worse.
And that has happened.
It's well-documented.
And statistically,
it's just a given.
We've now had over three
million people do the event.
Things happen.
If we took three million
days of people's lives,
statistically a certain
number have heart attacks
and other problems.
It just happens.
To give a very candid answer,
it's still very, very difficult
from the personal level.
You'd be very proud
of what you've built.
And you can look at
people who come to you
and they say, I lost 50 pounds,
or I overcame alcoholism,
or I beat depression
training for a Tough Mudder.
And the book talks about
some of that stuff.
But if somebody does your event
and they don't come back--
we've had a death
at our events--
it's very difficult. And I'm the
founder and CEO of the company.
As the CEO, the insurers
understand it, statistically it
happens.
Our rates are very, very
low because our events
are very safe.
They're safer than a
marathon or a triathlon.
But on a personal level,
it's very, very difficult
when something happens.
But I can sleep at night.
And I think I can
because I genuinely
believe we have the right
systems and processes in place.
And I believe people take
their responsibility--
and it is a responsibility--
very, very seriously.
And I think when you look at
the Tough Mudder environment,
we're trying to create
an environment that's
scary without being dangerous.
I'm sure many of you have
been on a roller coaster.
The whole idea of a roller
coaster is it's scary,
but I don't think
anyone really thinks
of it as being dangerous--
at least if you do one
here in the United States or
in Western Europe or something.
No, look, it's a serious point.
And I think--
I don't think you should ever
stop worrying about that.
We have events every weekend.
And I get an email every
end of day, every Saturday
and every Sunday, just to
say, yep, everyone got back.
And there are, of
course, sprained
ankles and cuts and bruises.
That's just a given
with an event.
But it is difficult.
But I believe
we have the right
systems and processes.
We have professionals in place.
We work with third parties
that review what we're doing.
But yeah, it's something you
have to take very seriously.
Before the first event,
trying to get insurance
was a challenge.
It really was.
It took a lot of
hard work and effort.
But now it's pretty
straightforward.
I still hear people say,
oh, that must be a liability
nightmare.
But it's really not.
I mean, you point to
three million data points
now to support your claim.
KERRY ANN KING: Yeah.
Ken and I spend a lot of
time worrying together.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering what's
your favorite obstacle and why?
WILL DEAN: Yeah.
So it's a funny thing to say.
My favorite obstacle is
one that we genuinely
invented by accident.
So the head of my
obstacle innovation lab
refers to it as Tough Mudder's
equivalent of penicillin.
We have an obstacle
called Block Ness Monster.
These guys are all
nodding at the front row,
oh, yeah, Block Ness Monster.
What Block Ness Monster
is, for those of you
that don't know it, is
it's a series of rotating--
they kind of look
like giant Toblerones,
and they spin around floating
on the surface of the water.
And you have to grab hold of it.
And then other people
spin it around,
and they flip you
back over and you
kind of land headfirst
back in the water.
It's really fun.
It's actually
somewhat challenging.
And it's almost impossible to do
on your own, almost impossible.
And so I really enjoy that.
I was doing it at the weekend.
We were being filmed
for some TV out there.
And it was just a great moment.
Everyone was working together.
And the presenter
I was with kind of
fell off the back of it.
And she was just laughing.
And I wasn't sure she
was going to be laughing,
so that was great.
But we genuinely invented
it by accident, as I said.
So Block Ness
Monster, the idea was
not that you kind
of climbed over it
and went down the other side.
But originally,
the idea was it was
going to be a replacement
for our balance beam
obstacle, Twinkle Toes, and you
were going to run across it.
And so we built this
thing, and it didn't work.
People just kept
falling off of it.
They either got straight
across, or they came off it
straightaway.
And people didn't
like it at all.
And then we just
observed, in this kind
of anthropological way, the
thing people were really
enjoying was trying to
get back onto the obstacle
because it was rotating.
And so we just
said, well, instead
of trying to take
people across it,
let's take them
over it that way.
And so it's become one of our
highest scoring obstacles.
So it checks a lot
of the boxes for us.
It's about teamwork.
It is somewhat
physically demanding.
You've got to really
hang on to it.
In its own kind of
way, it's a bit scary
because you kind of get plunged
headfirst back into the water.
But it's also fun.
And those are the four
values of Tough Mudder
all kind of combined into one.
So that's probably
my favorite obstacle.
AUDIENCE: You're in a
very competitive space.
And it's often
been called a fad.
How do you view
your competitors?
And what do you think gets
you to that next million Tough
Mudder participants?
WILL DEAN: Yes.
So I think it's--
you're right.
Since the first event,
people said, oh, great,
you did one event,
I'm not sure anyone
will come to the second event.
I will say in the
last year or two,
people have been
saying that a bit less.
I think people have kind of
figured out it's here to stay.
There is a community
that come back and do
these events every year.
But there's also
lots of new people
that come along and do them.
I think what was true
three or four years ago is
there were lots of people
entering this space.
And they said, oh,
I've got a farm.
I know how to build
some obstacles.
My brother-in-law can
build me a website.
I'll use my barn
for the logistics.
And some of these
things, frankly,
became glorified Ponzi schemes.
Because they sold some
tickets for the first event.
And then all the bills came
in for the first event.
They go, oh, I thought
I'd made money.
I better open three events
to pay for the first event.
And that kind of went
OK for a year or two.
But like all these things,
it comes to an end.
And I think Tough
Mudder as a company
has to do three or
four things well.
We now actually have quite a
large performance marketing
team that spend a
lot of time worrying
about 12-month
campaigns leading up
to every single individual
event, first thing.
Second, I think there's a
chicken and egg part to this.
We have the biggest obstacles,
so we get the most people.
Because we have
the most people, we
can build the biggest
and the best obstacles.
And there's something
of a flywheel effect
that happens there.
We have great partners.
We have three TV shows, CBS, CW,
Warner Brothers here in the US.
And then we have a partnership
in the UK with Sky Sports
and then with a social media
company that have just launched
a competitor to YouTube.
I believe it's called
Facebook Watch.
And so we have a bunch
of them, as well.
And so that helps increase
demand, engagement, brand
awareness, brand affinity.
And then you have great
partners, as well.
Lucozade, which is kind
of a British [INAUDIBLE]
of Gatorade, we're on the side
of 50 million bottles in the UK
this year-- which in a
country of 60 million people
is a huge number.
So I think the end result is you
have to do several things well.
And I think if you
look at the space,
there's really us
and one other player.
And Spartan, very much
about race, individual,
penalties if you fail.
And it's not that I
think that's wrong.
That's just not us.
And minivans and Porsches
have something in common,
but they're not really
marketing to the same people.
And I think in that regard--
and you can guess who I think
is the minivan in that equation,
but the truth is they are
quite different products.
And in the main, they attract
very different people.
There's actually a very low
level of customer overlap.
So does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KERRY ANN KING: So one more.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Will.
Thanks for coming.
I actually had pretty much the
same question, but I was just--
and I think it's all about--
it's an awesome experience.
How do you get people to
come back a second time?
And I guess maybe a
follow-up question
to that would be events,
as most people know,
are very, very expensive.
Your costs are very high
and ticket sales only
cover so much, so you
go into sponsorship.
And you guys have gotten
some really great partners.
What has been-- what to you
is a key in determining what's
worth a partnership or
a sponsorship versus you
never want that image of
selling yourself out just
to get the money?
Because you need it, from
a business perspective.
WILL DEAN: You do.
So I think-- there's a
few things from that.
So our repeat rate's
actually pretty high.
So our year-on-year
repeat rate's about 50%.
And that compares with about 9%
for a marathon or a triathlon.
So we're pretty happy with that.
And increasingly, our in-year
repeat rate's higher, as well.
So customer lifetime
value is now
in the thousands
of dollars for us.
Of course, we know our
customer acquisition costs.
They're going up, unfortunately.
You guys should
bear that in mind.
But there's a serious point
that we really think about that.
We have the Legionnaire program,
which for the repeaters,
you get different color
headbands, different obstacles.
We have a series of
different events--
5K, half, full, tougher,
toughest, world's toughest.
So there's a kind of
progression there, as well.
I think if you define us as an
events business in 2017, that's
half of our business.
We're a sports, media,
entertainment, lifestyle
company.
And I feel comfortable calling
us a lifestyle company,
because now 20,000 people have
had the logo tattooed on them.
And there aren't many
brands that can say that.
So how does our business work?
Well, you put on the events.
They have to break even.
That's a given.
And we kind of know how
many places in the world
you can go and do that.
And we have a pretty good sense
of how many people will show up
because we now have seven
years' worth of data.
You then have a media business
and a sponsorship business,
and those kind of coexist
and one fuels the other.
And then we have the training
business, so just launching
the gyms now.
We're moving to the
boot camp space.
And that really is the
kind of local community
hub to the event, mass
congregation of the tribe.
And I think of those
as an ecosystem.
And most businesses, you
start with one product.
And hopefully that goes well,
and you get your lucky break.
And I definitely got mine.
But then you hopefully
move into other things,
as well, which I
think we've done.
And we've tried to
create things that
reinforce the
underlying business
but are also consistent
with our values and mission
around building a tribe that
lives the values of teamwork
and camaraderie, fun, personal
accomplishments, and courage,
which I think we've tried
to do in everything.
And there are sponsors
we wouldn't work with.
that we do work
with that occasionally
want to go and do something
and we say, yeah,
no, we can't do
that, that won't work for us.
But I think the
partners that tend
to come with us are the
ones that understand
that in the long
term they don't win
if they piggyback
on our authenticity
rather than help build it.
KERRY ANN KING: So thank you
so much for being here, Will.
WILL DEAN: My pleasure.
Thank you for having me.
KERRY ANN KING: I highly
recommend the book.
It's an entertaining read
and almost has me ready
to do a Tough Mudder.
WILL DEAN: Almost, almost.
Good to know.
All right.
Well, look, thank you, guys.
It really was an
honor to be here.
[APPLAUSE]